si vous voulez acheter le Xiaomi le
redmi ne 12 5g et bien je vais vous
donner cette bonne raison de venir
l'acheter cette point positif sur ce
smartphone il y en a également deux qui
sont pas ouf je vous les dirai à la fin
donc restez bien jusqu'au bout de cette
vidéo comme ça vous saurez tout allez on
y va
le redmi note 12 5G alors je sais pas si
vous connaissez la famille de Xiaomi
mais il y a énormément de produits
ennemis qui sont sortis cette année il y
a le redmi notre 12,5 g qu'on a ici il
existe également un ennemi de 12 4G qui
sera un peu moins performant et un peu
moins cher il existe également et je
vous en ai déjà parlé à redmi de notre
12 Pro et un redmi ne le 12 Pro plus je
vous envoie allez voir à mon autre vidéo
pour tout savoir sur ce smartphone qui
vont forcément être un peu plus piqué
plus on va monter avec Pro et pro plus
plus on aura sous le capot et plus on
pourra en faire et là avec votre ennemi
notre 12 5g et bien on peut en faire et
vous avez le 4G qui est un peu en
dessous donc on commence avec le 4G le
5G le pro et le pro plus vous voyez il y
a une gamme qui est un petit peu large
dans ce milieu de gamme chez Xiaomi mais
aujourd'hui on se concentre vraiment sur
le modèle 5G pourquoi et bien parce que
aujourd'hui la 5G on la retrouve quand
même un peu partout c'est la norme le 4G
sera un peu moins cher mais si vous
pouvez mettre un peu plus d'argent je
vous recommande quand même le 5G alors 7
points 7 points c'est comme ça 7 points
à savoir le premier point et pour moi le
plus important et bien ça va être la
légèreté on est sur un smartphone qui
est ici super léger et un point très
très positif pour moi il fait
189 g et je vous assure qu'en termes de
légèreté on a un truc qui est vraiment
cool alors pour autant la prise en main
vous voyez j'arrive pas à faire le tour
complet au niveau de ma main j'aurais
aimé avoir un 60 peut-être un poil plus
fin ouais il faut vraiment que je vais
après pousser un peu les doigts faire un
peu de sport mais bon c'est pas très
grave ce qui est le plus important pour
moi ici c'est effectivement d'avoir de
la légèreté alors là le smartphone
j'aime bien la couleur parce que on est
sur un petit verre fourré alors il
existe également dans deux autres
couleurs on va voir le bleu givre et le
griotix mais ce petit verre fourré un
peu canard je dois reconnaître me plaît
quand même pas mal petit détail à venir
connaître également vous avez un capteur
d'empreintes digitale qui se situe ici
sur le côté je prends je pose mon doigt
ça déverrouille très rapidement c'est
bien c'est sécurisé ça ça me plaît le
deuxième point positif est bien c'est
cet écran parce que cet écran il est
déjà très grand donc ça c'est cool on
est sur du
6,67 pouces donc pour tout ce qui va
être contenu multimédia divertissement
vous avez franchement de quoi faire
c'est grand c'est bien alors
effectivement je vous le disais
l'inconvénient c'est le smartphone est
un petit peu grand mais l'avantage c'est
que vous avez cette grande dalle cette
grande diagonale donc gaming le
multimédia les films les séries tout ce
que vous voulez vous êtes vraiment
peinard et alors l'autre truc à venir
connaitre qui est super important c'est
que vous êtes ici sur une dalle AMOLED
c'est une dalle de Samsung et qui est
super canon alors ça veut dire plusieurs
choses déjà je vous montre regardez on
va aller dans l'écran la molette ça veut
dire quoi c'est lolette ça veut dire que
sont des pixels auto-émicistes ça veut
dire que chaque pixel va venir émettre
sa propre lumière à la différence du LCD
ce qui veut donc dire que lorsque je
passe vous voyez sur un thème sombre
comme ça et bien tous les pixels qui
vont être noir n'aimaient pas une
lumière noire ça veut dire qu'en fait
ils sont éteints c'est ce qu'on appelle
le noir profond ça veut donc dire que
tous les pixels qui sont éteint là ça va
être bon pour l'autonomie de mon
smartphone donc je vais pouvoir
l'emmener un peu plus loin donc ça c'est
vraiment un point qui est très très
positif déjà d'abord cette dalle à Molen
avec ses noirs profond c'est ce qu'on
appellera des contrastes infinies et
puis il y a un autre point qui est aussi
super cool c'est le taux de
rafraîchissement vous avez ici
aujourd'hui un taux d'actualisation qui
est mis à 60 hertz mais vous pouvez
venir le pousser jusqu'à 120 Hertz et
lui va faire le choix il va faire la
bascule intelligemment c'est à dire soit
du 60 hertz soit du 90 soit du 120 Hertz
en fonction besoin que vous allez avoir
un instant T donc si vous regardez des
films des séries 60 hertz ça consomme
moins si vous venez scroller comme un
Maboul sur Instagram sur je sais pas
quelle application et ben pouf il va
monter en 90 ou en 120 Hertz et si vous
arrivez sur un jeu qui nécessite du 120
Hertz ça va venir pousser jusqu'en 120
Hertz pour vous apporter le maximum de
fluidité donc vous voyez on est
complètement dans les clous ici et ça
c'est très très bien tout en sachant
qu'après on peut venir paramétrer son
schéma de couleur là il est mis en
intense et là ça va venir pousser un peu
plus alors on a le saturé sur saturé je
trouve que c'est un peu trop bon il y a
des gens qui aiment bien quand c'est sur
saturé le standard je trouve un petit
peu trop fade ça jaunit un peu l'écran
c'est pas mal mais vous mettez en
intense comme ça c'est pas mal après on
peut venir modifier la température de
couleur vous pouvez vous mettre alors le
chaud il est un petit peu trop chaud je
vous laisse quand même le par défaut et
une fois de plus le froid je trouve un
petit peu trop sur le violine donc vous
restez en par défaut et vous mettez en
un temps c'est pas mal au moins vous
avez un équilibre qui est quand même
correct ici tout en sachant qu'ici on a
une luminosité maximale de 1210 je dis
bien maximal parce que sinon on est
quand même sur du 450000 ça veut dire
que si vous allez en extérieur vous
allez voir correctement attention plus
vous allez pousser la luminosité et plus
vous allez venir consommer au niveau de
la batterie ça il faut le savoir autre
point qui est positif au niveau de cet
écran vous avez une résolution on full
HD+ donc vous voyez on a une dalle qui
est bien et une fois de plus pour tout
ce qui est multimédia c'est très cool le
troisième point positif est bien c'est
la batterie vous avez une grosse
batterie de 5000 milliampères heure sur
tous les smartphones d'entrée milieu de
gamme les constructeurs viennent mettre
des grosses batteries pourquoi parce que
l'autonomie c'est pas uniquement la
taille de la batterie c'est également le
processeur c'est également les techno de
RAM c'est également l'écran je vous l'ai
dit le fait d'avoir un écran OLED des
versus LCD ça va venir jouer un petit
peu ça va être l'expérience logiciel
bref il y a plein de choses qui vient
jouer au niveau de la batterie mais
comme ici on a pas les processeurs les
plus performants qui vont être les moins
énergivores et bien on met des très
grosses batteries pour venir compenser
un petit peu tout ça donc là vous avez
une batterie de 5000 mAh c'est quand
même très bien et dans les clous par
rapport à ce qu'on attend d'un
smartphone dans cette gamme de prix là
donc ça me permettra d'emmener de
l'autonomie assez loin un jour un jour
et demi ça va dépendre une fois de plus
vous de vos usages ça nous emmène au 4e
point qui est important et bien c'est
que vous avez un bloc de charge qui
inclut alors aujourd'hui il y a de moins
en moins de Bob de charge ici vous en
avez un dans la boîte vous avez un gros
bloc de charge de 33 watts ça c'est cool
parce que ça vous permet de le recharger
quand même assez rapidement alors c'est
pas la recharge la plus rapide du monde
soyons clairs 33 watts mais néanmoins ça
vous permet de venir recharger vos
smartphones rapidement vous êtes
tranquille alors il faut s'armer de
patience avoir un peu plus d'une heure
devant soi pour venir recharger sa
batterie de 5000 milliampères heure de 0
à 100 % pour autant attention et je vous
l'ai déjà dit dans une précédente vidéo
vous ne laissez pas votre smartphone
tomber en dessous des 20 % et vous ne
rechargez pas au dessus des 80 % tout ça
pour venir préserver à la durée de vie
de votre batterie donc en gros ouais
vous comptez une heure à peu près grosso
merdo pour venir le recharger et là vous
êtes peinard le cinquième point et qui
est aussi important
et que vous allez sous le capot en
termes de performance ici on a un
processeur de Qualcomm c'est le stade
dragon 4 Jane 1 qui est gravé par TSM
c'est un peu dans le détail TSMC c'est
la grosse entreprise leader qui vient
faire de la gravure qui est basée à
Taïwan qui est notamment au présent au
niveau de la guerre qu'on va retrouver
entre la Chine et Taïwan au niveau des
technologies ils ont vraiment ces
technologies gravures qui sont très très
fortes et très très bien poussé donc
welcome qui est l'entreprise américaine
vient faire graver ici sur un dragon 4
gn1 directement à Taïwan car toutes les
meilleures techno pour venir graver il
est gravé ici en sidanomètre on les
passe sur les processeurs avec les
finesses de gravure les plus basses on
n'est pas sur du Cap nanomètres
néanmoins ce qu'on a ici ça marche très
bien on est sur un processeur 5g et
surtout ce qui est intéressant de m'y
retenir c'est que ce processeur est plus
dans le milieu de gamme c'est quoi le
com mais pour autant vous allez pouvoir
faire tourner des jeux du Play Store
sans problème vous allez avoir de la
fluidité ça c'est un truc qui est très
important c'est à dire que vous voyez
lorsque je viens switcher j'ai ouvrir
une application et bien ça réagit ça me
l'ouvre directement lorsque j'ai ouvert
mes thèmes tac paf ça ouvre directement
lorsque je veux aller j'en sais rien moi
par exemple sur l'application Mister
alors le pour se connecter bien
évidemment mais sinon ça réagit c'est
assez rapide voyez donc ça c'est quand
même cool parce que c'est rapide mais
switcher on arrive rapidement envoyer
sur les paramètres c'est réactif ça
marche bien pas de souci donc ça c'est
vraiment aussi un point qui est très
positif alors il existe en France
uniquement la version avec 4 Go de RAM
j'aurais pu aimer que les autres
versions parce qu'il existe également ce
smartphone en 6 Go de RAM et en 8g de
RAM et on l'a pas en France donc ici
uniquement du 4 giga de ram la techno
c'est de la lpdr4x qui est très correct
ici sans aucun problème et on a ici une
version uniquement en 128 gigaoctets de
stockage il existe une version 256 mais
on ne l'a pas en France et la techno de
stockage c'est de l'UFS de point 2 qui
n'est pas non plus la dernière mais dans
cette gamme de prix c'est normal c'est
très convenable et ça ira très bien tu
t'en sachant qu'ici en plus on peut
venir l'augmenter jusqu'à un terrain
donc ça c'est cool également et alors
puisqu'on en est là je vais vous montrer
le petit point de détail qui n'est pas
un point de détail et qui a un important
au niveau de votre tiroir de carte SIM
c'est que regardez lorsque vous l'ouvrez
vous voyez vous avez la possibilité de
mettre une extension de carte mémoire
micro SD jusqu'à 1 t le sixième point
sixième point qui est intéressant c'est
l'expérience log
iciel alors on est bien évidemment
chercher Xiaomi ça vous aura pas échappé
on est sur mi-way 14 qui est une bonne
expérience logicielle alors ce que
j'aime bien chez meway 14 c'est
qu'effectivement et bien ça va être
lisible on va retrouver des icônes de
couleurs il y a des petites séparations
avec un trait pour vraiment venir
comprendre les différentes parties je
dirais qu'ici on est basé sur Android 12
on n'a pas un Android 13 bon c'est pas
très très grave ici sur ce smartphone ça
me pose pas de souci vous pouvez venir
personnaliser bien évidemment votre fond
d'écran personnalisé vos différents
thèmes très facilement d'ailleurs vous
avez pas mal de choix au niveau du
catalogue au niveau des fonds d'écran
votre écran d'accueil également autant
le menu principal est bien autant les
souvenirs sont un peu plus tristounets
mais bon globalement vous voyez c'est
assez lisible là on a bien toutes les
informations sur la batterie on voit ce
qu'il vous reste bref l'expérience
logiciel chez Xiaomi se trouve plutôt
cool alors après ce qu'on peut venir
reprocher c'est qu'il y a pas mal
d'applications qui sont préinstallées on
va avoir notamment de l'Opéra ce qui est
quand même pas mal comme navigateur
Xiaomi community il y a pas mal de
petites applications globalement si vous
en foutez vous les utilisez pas un
Aliexpress ici bon voilà mais
globalement je trouve l'expérience est
bien alors vous avez le choix lorsque
vous l'installer soit mettre le tiroir
d'application là soit ne pas mettre de
tiroir d'application glob bon je préfère
le tiroir d'application donc
l'expérience logiciel pour moi ici c'est
un point positif septième point positif
et bien si vous voulez deux cartes SIM
5G
et bingo
la voix vous avez effectivement une
double carte nano SIM 5G donc si vous
voulez de la 5G vous pouvez avoir de la
5G ou alors une carte nano Simpson j'ai
plus une carte micro SD jusqu'à un
terrain ça je vous l'ai dit juste avant
donc ça c'est vraiment un point positif
alors il y a d'autres points positifs
qui sont très cool c'est que vous avez
en plus ici de l'infrarouge donc si vous
voulez utiliser votre smartphone comme
une télécommande vous pouvez le faire
alors vous le voyez il y a également une
prise jack ça c'est très très bien donc
ça c'est un point qui est très positif
parce que je vous parlerai tout à
l'heure de l'audio vous allez voir c'est
un petit peu en dessous en plus un
smartphone qui est certifié résistant à
l'eau et à la poussière avec une
certification
ip53 on a pas une IP67 on a pas une
épaisse 68 donc on dirait à moins loin
mais on a quand même une certification
IP euh 53 donc ça c'est cool on a bien
évidemment du NFC pour le paiement des
réaliser et on a un indice de
réparabilité il faut le savoir de 7,6
sur 10 et puis le huitième point je
dirais c'est le tarif de ce smartphone
c'est pas le moins cher les moins chers
il faut aller bien évidemment sur le
redmi note 12 4G ou il va commencer à un
peu moins de 200 balles à 199,90 € sur
la version ici 4 giga de ram + 128 Go de
stockage on est à 299 €, 90 qui reste un
tarif quand même relativement maîtrisé
pour ce smartphone qui est quand même
très cool et une fois de plus s'il vous
intéresse je vous mets un lien juste en
bas dans la description alors maintenant
j'ai deux points qui sont quand même
relativement en dessous le premier ça va
être l'expérience audio autant ils nous
ont mis un très très belle écran ici qui
est très très cool de 6,67 pouces en
AMOLED et ça c'est vachement bien autant
l'audio vous avez un seul haut-parleur
c'est un haut-parleur mono qui est pas
ouf il est là il est assez criard il a
assez médium voilà je suis pas
complètement fan de cette expérience
audio donc là par contre je vous l'ai
dit le point positif quand même parce
qu'il y a quand même du positif dans ce
négatif là c'est que vous avez
effectivement et bien cette prise jack
donc on peut venir brancher un petit
casque filaire si on le souhaite et puis
sinon vous avez du Bluetooth 5.1 pour
venir appairer des écouteurs très
facilement des écouteurs de Xiaomi par
exemple tu en as un exemple il y en a
plein d'autres mais j'ai des redmi buds
scat pro que je peux venir mettre ici
donc ça c'est aussi un point qui est
assez positif et le deuxième point
négatif c'est la partie photo alors
regardez vous allez avoir trois capteurs
à l'arrière le capteur principal que
vous avez juste en haut ici et bien
c'est votre capteur grand angle c'est un
capteur de 48 mégapixels ok vous avez en
dessous un ultra grand angle de 8
mégapixels et là vous avez un tout petit
capteur non mais sur le côté c'est de la
macro c'est du 2 mégapixels et à l'avant
vous avez également un capteur qui est
planqué juste ici c'est du 13 mégapixels
au niveau de la caméra de selfie tout en
sachant que c'est pas parce qu'on vous
dit qu'un capteur est en 48 mégapixels
que c'est forcément bien c'est lié à
plein de choses déjà c'est la qualité du
capteur tous les capteurs de 48
mégapixels ne se valent pas loin de là
ça dépend également du traitement qui va
être fait d'un point de vue logiciel à
l'intérieur donc vous allez voir que
d'un capteur de 48 mégapixels à un autre
globalement c'est pas la même histoire
donc méfiez-vous vraiment des fiches
techniques c'est pas parce qu'il y a
écrit 48 mégapixels que c'est forcément
bien si vous regardez les photos je
trouve que déjà sur le grand angle il y
a un côté un peu trop violine et ça
c'est vraiment un point pas ouf c'est
que la colorimétrie est pas très
équilibrée là c'est un peu violet on le
voit au niveau des nuages dans le ciel
on le voit aussi un petit peu au niveau
de la façade ça va manquer un peu de
détails et puis il y a un côté avec un
petit effet voile que je trouve pas
foufou l'ultra grand-angle ça manque de
piquer énormément mais ça ne fait pas
surprenant ça déconne pas sur un
smartphone dans cette gamme de prix là
donc c'est pas très dérangeant et après
on vient zoomer c'est du zoom numérique
on part effectivement du 48 mégapixels
et on vient zoomer donc on va voir la
même colorimétré un petit peu trop
violide ici et je trouve pas ça foufou
tout en sachant que sur cette ultra
grand temps je trouve ultra grand-angle
par contre lui il est un petit peu trop
vert donc là il y a une différence entre
le côté un peu trop violet on le voit au
niveau des nuages le côté un peu trop
vert on le voit également au niveau des
nuages et après on vient on se
rapprocher bon on évite de trop se
rapprocher parce qu'à un moment ça veut
plus trop en faire et c'est vraiment ce
que je vais venir reprocher un pas sur
smartphone c'est à dire que il permet
d'avoir quand même quelques souvenirs
sur le grand angle sans venir trop
zoomer vous venez vous rapprocher on
peut choper un peu à l'ultra grandement
quelques souvenirs également mais en
terme de photo c'est pas foufou la
colorimétrie est pas dingue on va
souffrir un petit peu également au
niveau des hautes lumières à quelques
endroits mais bon dans cette gamme de
prix c'est pas très très surprenant vous
voyez là c'est pareil je trouve pas ça
fou fou la colorimétrie violine là c'est
un petit peu trop vert et on évite de
venir se rapprocher parfois j'ai même eu
un petit peu de mal à faire le point là
voyez sur la fleur devant et ça c'est la
moto que je viens de dire un peu lui
reprocher alors après autre point de
détails je vous le montre regardez
est-ce que vous voyez la différence
parce que là je suis en maquereau et je
me rapproche et en fait il y a une vraie
différence qui se fait au niveau du
capteur c'est très surprenant pour voir
parce qu'en fait c'est exactement
macro je prends en fait j'ai
l'impression que la macro plus je me
rapproche et je vais venir changer
d'optique là je pense que je suis sur le
petit 48 mégapixels et lorsque je me
rapproche je suis sur le petit 2
mégapixels et c'est là où ça va vraiment
venir déconner et où c'est pas terrible
regardez c'est vraiment la même chose là
vous voyez donc là il y a un truc au
niveau logiciel qui est pas fou alors la
macro elle est pas très précise elle est
pas très jolie mais c'est pas déconnant
regardez la voyez parler la
colorimétrich change pour voir que c'est
effectivement la même chose au même
endroit c'est juste que je me rapproche
un petit peu donc bon il y a un truc qui
est pas fou fou au niveau de cette macro
là mais c'est pas surprenant non plus
sur un capteur de mégapixels c'est
jamais terrible là je suis venu chercher
un petit peu de contre-jour voyez au
niveau de l'ultra grand-angle il a
toujours un petit peu de mal vous voyez
grand angle ultra grand-angle bon il y a
beaucoup de limites au niveau de ce
smartphone la caméra de selfie aussi il
y a vraiment pas du tout de piquer on
manque vraiment de netteté ici au niveau
du visage il y a coté un peu un peu
lissé il y a côté comme espèce de fait
voile faudrait bien corriger un peu le
voile et c'est un peu tout ce que je
veux dire reprocher au niveau de de ce
smartphone et je trouve ça vraiment pas
terrible et ça regardez je vous le
montre c'est vraiment quand je fais du
shooter avec la macro là je suis comme
ça hop et là je viens de rapprocher et
vous voyez là ça change vraiment
complètement c'est très surprenant parce
que je reste vraiment uniquement sur la
macro et j'ai ce changement qui est
comme ça et ah il y a un truc qui marche
pas regardez je vous montre la même
chose là sur une fleur un peu rouge donc
complètement rouge vous voyez je suis en
macro et hop PAF dès que je me rapproche
ça change complètement de couleur alors
pour autant je sais pas si c'est un
changement d'objectif parce que ça il y
a pas de décalage mais d'un point de vue
logiciel il y a un truc qui est quand
même déconnant ici alors verdict final
qu'est-ce que vaut ce Xiaomi redmi note
12 5G alors soyons clairs on est un
petit peu moins de 300 balles un peu
moins de 300 balles on va pas s'attendre
à avoir un smartphone qui fait 11 et
merveilles il va pas tout faire par
contre moi les gros points positifs que
je viens retenir ici et je vous l'ai dit
c'est effectivement ce grand écran
AMOLED qui est très bien qui est très
cool pour venir regarder du contenu
multimédia je vous conseille de venir
écouter avec un casque attention pas
trop fort pas tout le temps parce que
pour vos oreilles c'est pas ouf mais
c'est là vous aurez la meilleure
expérience multimédia donc pour le
multimédia pour le gaming on a
smartphone qui est suffisamment
performant on a une très belle dalle on
a une bonne expérience qui globalement
est quand même super cool on a une
autonomie qui se tient et qui est bien
on a de la charge rapide avec un
chargeur inclus donc c'est un smartphone
qui coche beaucoup de cases même si il
est pas ouf en photo on peut quand même
avoir quelques souvenirs il reste donc
pour moi très honnête et très
intéressant à un peu moins de 300 balles
et une fois de plus s'il vous intéresse
je vous mets juste un lien en bas dans
la description vous pouvez y aller voilà
tout ce que j'avais à vous raconter
aujourd'hui sur ce redmi note 12 5G je
pense que vous en pensez ce que vous
avez déjà eu un smartphone de Xiaomi de
la gamme redmi de 12 est-ce que ça
aurait mis 125 g peut vous tenter est-ce
qu'il vous botte oui non pas compte en
sachant qu'effectivement si vous voulez
ce smartphone avec ce bel écran et bien
vous l'aurez également sur le redmi de
12 4G vous aurez également la même dalle
vous aurez la même taille de batterie
vous aurez la même chargeur vous n'aurez
pas par contre le même processeur on
dira un petit peu moins loin mais
globalement bon voilà si vous voulez une
bonne expérience multimédia que vous en
fichez d'avoir de la 5G le redmi de 12
4G peut aussi être intéressant une fois
de plus je vous mets également un lien
en bas dans la description voilà je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous et on se
voit très bientôt pour continuer à
parler tech parler de Xiaomi mais
également pas d'autres marques ça c'est
bien à bientôt prenez soin de vous Ciao
[Musique]